Hello.
And welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live.
I'm your host, Rawkode. Now before we begin,
I just wanna take a brief moment to
say thank you to Equinix Medal. They are
my employer and they provide the time resources
for me to invest in the show, thank
great hosts, and get
find experts to come and share their knowledge
with us so we can all learn together.
If you wanna check out Equinix metal piece,
feel free to use the code Rawkode dash
live. This will get you $50 in credit.
That's roughly around a hundred hours if you
spend it wisely.
But go the fun route and spend it
much quicker with larger machines.
So today, we are gonna take a look
at the OperatorSDK.
And I'm very fortunate to be joined by
a colleague of mine,
Dennis Kelly. Hello, Dennis. How are you?
I'm great. Thanks for having me today.
No. My pleasure. Definitely. So you are a
you work for Equinix Medal too, which is
fantastic. So, know Yeah. And you are a
staff Kubernetes engineer. So you spend a a
great deal of your time working with Kubernetes.
Do you wanna
give a quick introduction of yourself, and then
we'll talk about the OperatorSDK as well?
Absolutely.
Denovan diesel is my Twitter handle, and you
can find me there and ask questions later
if you want. My nickname is Deno, but
I also go by Dennis.
I work on our delivery engineering team here
at Equinix Metal, and we stand up the
Tinkerbell API that we use for provisioning
on our Kubernetes clusters.
Actually, only been here a few months, but
already learning a ton and excited with the
work I'm doing on the OperatorSDK
and
happy to share that today.
Awesome. I think we actually joined roughly around
the same time, if I remember correctly. Yeah.
We have our first comment already. So Hannah
says, excited for this talk. And I think
they possibly know you because they say, hey.
So hi.
Yes.
And I I need to give a shout
out to Hannah,
and correct everyone on the proper way to
say Kate's and that's CooperNoodles.
So we'll be doing some CooperNoodling today.
CooperNoodles.
You know, I like it. I'm on board
with that for sure. So
can you
tell us just
in a summary, what is the OperatorSDK?
Well,
even to back up a little further, let's
talk first What are Kubernetes?
Yeah.
Hopefully,
people understand what Kubernetes is, but the Kubernetes
operator
is,
just an extension of the Kubernetes API.
When you think about interacting with Kubernetes
cluster using kubectl
or kubectl, however you wish to pronounce it,
you you
can then extend
the Kubernetes API to do, like, custom
automatic programmatic
things and,
define custom resources within your,
Kubernetes
cluster.
And,
you know, it's very popular in kind of
like the DevOps y,
area that I work in because,
you know, there's things that you wanna do
like backups or,
you know, customized automated deployments. Say you wanna
create your own auto scaler,
the Kubernetes operator
provides a powerful platform to automate a lot
of those tasks.
And,
the OperatorSDK,
while it's also while it's available in Golang
and what will feature today, you can also
do this with Ansible and Helm,
and
other
platforms, but, it's just a very powerful platform
that kind of bootstraps
your operator development environment and makes it easy
for you to,
develop operators for your environment.
Okay.
So what we're we're gonna write an operator
today, if I'm not mistaken. Is that is
that correct? Yes. We're gonna do a
very simple case. We're gonna call this the
add operator where we basically take two
add ins and compute the sum.
And
while typically your operators are gonna interact more
so with objects and resources within
the Kubernetes ecosystem,
This will at least demonstrate how to get
up and running with some simple business logic,
but then we'll also wire in some useful
tools that you would actually use
for interacting with
those other resources.
Okay. Will we be running today's operator and
say that for Kubernetes cluster?
We sure will. Alright. I've always like you
know, I've I've dabbled in this in the
past and never really been terribly successful.
And I think it's just always the that
development environment and how you how you work
with it, how you get it. And so
I'm looking forward to just seeing you kinda
break all that down for us and and
Yeah. Absolutely.
Learn a lot. So should we get your
screen up when we get started? Yes.
Yeah. Let's go there.
So here you see I have a Mac
with a terminal open.
Really, the only prerequisites
to
building this is having make installed
and having Golang.
And I'm using I think it's
1.15
and then the OperatorSDK.
The latest version is
1.2.
That's what I have downloaded, and you can
get that using brew.
And so
when building an operator
with Golang
and the operator SDK, you're gonna wanna start
in a directory that's in your go path.
And so that's why I have this go
source GitHub
demo van diesel.
And
I'm just gonna make a directory here
for our new
operator,
and we'll close this guy down for a
minute.
We got some
commands here.
I'll copy and paste because I am not
the best typer in the world.
And so we're gonna knit this directory.
We're gonna just gonna use the domain example.com,
and that's basically the domain name for
the,
schema that we're going to create.
And I'll list me as the owner, d
e kelly at equinix dot
com. Here,
it's gonna leverage the controller runtime
and,
basically set up our directory
with all this, boilerplate,
code.
And you can see we have a make
file, a Docker file, a bin where it's
already built our first manager with basically nothing
inside of it. And the next thing it's
gonna want us to do is create our
API.
Okay. Do mind if I ask you a
few questions as we go? No. Please.
So,
like, you know, I I've I've never done
this before. So some of these questions will
be hopefully
just to clarify my own understanding. But the
operator SDK
has a a binary as a command that
you have installed.
It's just for it's just for this boilerplate
stuff. Right? It's it doesn't really do anything
else. Everything else is consumed, I'm guessing, by
something in the go mod that points to
the operator SDKs.
Correct.
So
OperatorSDK
is just creating
the the directory structure for us and
building our initial
main .go, which is gonna kind of be
the manager that gets built. And the manager
will then have controllers
for the operator
and, you know, and then when you want
to say
apply a custom resource
that is of this type, it'll go to
the reconciler for the operator
to do the business logic, compute everything, and
return the results.
Okay. Sweet. And that domain flag that you
have passed, is that gonna be like a
prefix for API version? Like, is that what
separates out from other controllers?
This one I have highlighted.
So, like, the initial
operator
in it that we just ran just sets
up the directory structure,
and then we're going to actually add the
schema to our API with this next tab.
Okay. And I guess I just sorry. And
you go.
Go ahead. I I guess I just didn't
understand the --domainexample.com
in the previous command.
So, like, when you create a resource in
Kubernetes,
you're telling it it's
it it has this schema and it's typically
domain.com/v1
or whatever.
And so that's all it's
that's using that in the Okay. The custom
resource definition.
And so it can be anything that you
want it to be.
Example.com
is just kind of the the default.
But typically,
you're creating your own schema to extend Kubernetes,
you would use your own domain name.
Okay.
Thanks.
And it'll make more sense here in a
minute too.
Because now we're creating this add operator, and
we're just gonna put it in a group
called math. Because say we wanna do a
subtract subtraction or a multiplication operator later, we
can still add it to the same project
or
just have it part of that schema group.
And so
And so now we have kind of all
the files that we need to start developing
the operator, and we'll start here with
the the main entry point.
And so you can see it's,
you know, using the controller runtime
to
set up everything.
And the nice thing about this is behind
the scenes, it's creating the manager for the
operator
and adding in a lot of features that
you'll want down the road, like,
automatic,
collection of metrics.
You can do leader election if you want
to say run multiple
replicas.
And and then it's just wiring in our
controller into the manager and then starting it
up.
And so there is one
addition to the controller that I'd like to
add is
oftentimes with custom or with resources, you're gonna
want to
add a recorder so that you can
publish events.
So say
your operator is, you know, building up a
new application, it may take time for it
to, you know, download the image,
deploy
the container,
and you can then, since it's asynchronous,
you can, publish these events so people can
then check-in
on the kind of status of their
resources being built. And so the manager already
includes a record or has a recorder, so
we're just gonna add this to
our reconciler
right here.
And so we were creating an event recorder
for add.
And,
you know, other things you could do is,
you know, here we have a logger that's
set to use dev mode. You could say
add another flag
to your, container startup that says, you know,
whether or not you wanna use dev for
production.
Just have that be a boolean and then
have that specified here when you set up
your login.
And so the nice thing about it is
it really,
you know, sets you up to, like, really
focus on your own business logic and
your own,
APIs and controllers.
And so since we created the API under,
v one beta one,
we then go into our ad types, and
this will be the schema
for
our operator.
And I've, again, kind of prebuilt this before.
And, again, I'll just copy and paste,
and you'll see it bigger here on this
screen.
And so, again, this is kind of a
template scaffolding
file.
Add spec is
how we define the desired state of the
operator.
And so
what we wanna be able to do is
take two add ins and compute the sum.
And so what we're going to submit to
the API are those two add ins. We're
gonna say they're integers,
and then
there's a next thing we do for the
status is the observed state. And so when
it's all said and done, we wanna have
that sum computed
and available.
And
so, you know, this really defines the the
API that we're building for this operator.
We really don't have to do anything else
with it because our ad spec and ad
status then become part of the ad
struck ad list.
And then we the schema builder will register
those two new schemas
or custom resource definitions within the the cluster.
Okay. So when we ran that last generate
command, I noticed that it add I asked
you two questions. Do you want to add
a resource and add a controller? So, like,
that boilerplate is just an empty custom resource
definition with a controller that's watching it, and
then we have to then decide
what gets in that spec, what gets in
that status. And that's you're just adding that
to the obstructs, like. Yeah.
And it's it's easy as that. And so
the last one
it can created was our controller.
And again, kind of boilerplate
code,
and and so it's setting up our reconciler
and our logging for you.
And so one thing that we did with
our reconciler
is we added in an event recorder.
And so
we're gonna want to
also add that to the definition of our
controller here.
And I'll and then demonstrate how to use
that.
And so the reconciler
has within it your logging,
the,
schema,
and then it also includes a Kubernetes client
so that we can
then,
query to, like, either list, create, update,
objects within Kubernetes.
And so
what we're gonna do here
is I'm gonna kind of bring in some
more boilerplate.
Because what we're gonna wanna do is when
we receive
one of these custom resources
for the ad, we're gonna pull in that
as a as a what we call our
instance.
And so it's of type math b one
beta one
and that ad
struct that we created in our ad types
over here.
And so this ad struct is gonna have
metadata,
the ad spec, the ad status, and that
is the object that we're working with in
Kubernetes.
We use our reconciler client
to get that
instance.
And then we're just, you know, kind of
checking errors
and also recording events based on those errors.
So,
someone wouldn't have to necessarily go into
log files to debug problems
with their custom resource that they just created.
They could just describe it and see, you
know, what error had occurred.
And so if the error is that it's
not found, we want to
just return it and requeue.
But if we have a problem reading it,
then we're gonna retry reading that request.
And so that's all we're doing here with
the boilerplate.
And then
the
next thing that we're gonna do is just
up,
compute our sum.
And update the status.
And so
here, the instance dot status sum is coming
from the spec of our two edits.
And then
once we calculate that sum, we want to
update that object in Kubernetes.
And so here, we're doing this using
our Kubernetes client again, the status
update
on that instance because then it will publish
the sum into that custom resource.
And, again, using logging
to
and event recording here to post errors.
And, yeah, I found the event recorder to
be super helpful because that way
operators can easily obtain information
about the status of their custom resource without
having to go to log files.
Yeah. I think it's one of my biggest
frustrations when I'm working with Kubernetes is, like,
the event log is just sitting there empty,
and I'm like, well, nothing's working, and I
have to start Yeah. Hunting down every log
from everything I I can find. Like Yeah.
Yeah. And
so this function down here is set up
with manager. That is what gets called in
our main go routine to add this controller
to the manager.
And so
we created
the repository
as, you know, the add operator, but we
could say change the name to MASH dash
operator and add additional controllers
into this. So
and, you know, having these as kind of
your
boilerplate
files, we could copy it over and create
say a subtraction spec
and a subtraction controller.
Okay. So and your
experience
then, do you think it's better to do
you separate out all these reconcilers
to be their own different controllers?
Or do you use one controller that kinda
monitors multiple resources? Like, what is the best
practice there?
I think it really depends on, like, the
business and, you know, as always, like, the
business and the situation.
Like, I I like I like to think
of the operator as a manager of controllers.
And so,
sometimes there's different operations that you wanna do
with from within, like, the same management organis
so if you're thinking about people, you're gonna
have a manager, and then you have multiple
operators working for that manager. And those operators,
you know, are gonna have these reconcilers, like
the procedures that it runs
for to do specific tasks.
And so, you know, based on
the request,
you know, that's gonna define, like, the API.
That's the request coming in. And then there's
a procedure to run on those specific,
values.
And so you can have multiple operators
or controllers under one manager,
and we're actually doing that with more
extensive
operators that we're using in production.
And it and it just makes sense. You're
deploying one pod and they and they kind
of share a lot of the same back
end code
in terms of other business logic that it's
gonna perform.
But if they really don't share any code,
it's fine also separating them up.
Okay. Cool. Thanks.
And so,
you know, now that we've built
our the functionality to do everything,
we're gonna
we're
gonna generate the configs
for this because
we went in and updated
our schema here. And so when you update
the schema
of your
controller,
you then need to recompute the custom resource
definitions,
and it's doing it from this code. So
that way, we don't have to
build all of that YAML ourselves.
Is that with that weird comment syntaxes with
the pluses at the start? Is that a
I mean,
is that a Golang thing or is that
just something the operator SDKs is parsing out
of the the code?
Yeah. That's the upper like, the controller
generator.
It's taking a look at this ad types
and then generating
the spec
based on this Golang file. Okay.
See lines thirty seven thirty eight, they look
special.
And it's it's not something that I I've
seen before in Go. I just wasn't sure
if that's a Go thing. Is this just
an operator cube builder thing? Like It's a
it's a operator.
So it's using those as annotations.
Alright. Okay.
And so we can now see
we'll use
so we have our map.example.com
ads.
And based on the file that we
created in Golang,
it's created our
custom resource definition that will get added to
Kubernetes.
Well, even that's all the open API stuff.
And
then
one thing I won't do live here is
pushing or building the
the
building the manager, our our operator, and pushing
that to a repository.
Then, you know, I'm
I don't have the greatest Internet. It would
take a really long time. So I've already
pushed this to
a cluster,
but
I can show you what
you would need to do to make that
happen here as well.
So
what you're gonna wanna do is,
you know, add this custom resource
to your cluster. So I'm just k apply
the config CRD basis.
And then
you'll push the
role in binding
because, again, all of these are
generated for you.
So you'll apply that
and then apply the role binding.
And we're just going with the defaults right
now, but you can go in,
and,
you know, change the namespaces
and the
user that you wanna use
for all of this. And the config manager
manager
is actually what deploys
the operator.
And that's done after you do
because here in the make file, you can
see,
all your options.
And so,
like, manager will actually build the operator for
you,
and and then you can also do a
docker build, and that will put it in
an actual container and then push it. And
in our case, we're pushing it to a
COI back end.
And
so with this operator now deployed,
we can
create our custom resource. And so
this is where that example.com
comes in because here our API version
is math.example.comv
1 beta one.
The type of,
the kind is add.
We're giving it a name of five plus
seven.
Hopefully, I didn't screw anything up in the
cluster.
And then we can
k get.
And
we'll wanna do minus o YAML here.
So you can see the spec had these
two add ins, five and seven, and we
define that in our add dot types. We
computed the sum and pushed it back to
this custom resource.
Sweet.
And so yeah. That's the, like, very
basic
business logic.
You know, oftentimes,
you know, you'll be submitting
values
to, say, pull a list of pods in
and then
perform some action on those pods based on
the output of what's currently running.
And then your custom resource definition will keep
that
group of pods in that this consistent state
all the time.
Okay. Able
yeah.
So
I just
I I I wanna understand this. I'm gonna
just throw some complete newbie questions at you
here. Like,
the boilerplate that you've built. Right? I mean,
you only added, like, five lines of code
to this to this project. Right?
And does this magic reconcile
function which is being called? Now what triggers
that reconcile
to happen?
So,
basically,
this
reconciler
is we're what basically, what we're doing is
extending the Kubernetes API
to support
new schema.
And so what triggers the the
reconciler
is when we add this custom resource here.
So this is the API version and this
is the kind. And because we uploaded that
custom resource definition into the cluster,
Kubernetes now recognize this as this as a
resource
within the cluster.
And so
and if you look, here's the self link,
apismap.example.comv1beta1
namespace system ads, and then this is the
name of our,
custom resource.
And so, basically, we're just creating a new
resource in Kubernetes
because, like, you know, by default, it supports,
you know, pods and secrets and,
you know, all the various resources within
Kubernetes
environment ecosystem,
and we're extending that API to support this
mass operation.
Okay. So if you modify that fail and
change the five
to 31
and apply it again, does that cause the
reconciled to then rerun and update the status?
Yeah. We can keep the same name. So
it'd be it'd still be the same resource,
but we'll change this to a seven.
And so here, it it didn't say that
we created five plus seven. We configured five
plus seven. We're changing the state of it.
And so then
even though the name of the resource is
five plus seven,
we have a new sum.
Cool. And that's just all provided by the
operator SDK hooking up everything that we need.
So you really when you said you just
need to write the business logic, like, that's
that's that's a pretty cool way of doing
it. No. Like, I I found this to
be super powerful and cool because, like, you
basically get to dive right into your own
business logic and, you know, say you wanna
start scaling pods. You can, you know, get
information about the pods, based on the metadata
that you provided.
And then, like, oh, we're at a certain
we're at a certain low level.
Let's, say add two more, pods and scale
the app.
Okay. Nice. I like it.
Yeah.
And and so, yeah, it has a lot
of applications for software developers, DevOps,
security,
even testing because you can, you know, mock
mock failure situations
within an operator
to, you know, test your environment.
So but it's a really powerful platform for,
you know, managing Kubernetes.
K. Definitely. I can I can see what's
I pretty much believe this is is so
appealing?
Just, like, I find the code and right
away that things is running inside the cluster
monitor and custom resources, subscribing to events in
the Kubernetes API, and then call the record
cell phone. I mean, there's a lot going
on there under the hood and Yeah. Absolutely.
And then, you know, the deeper you get
into it, you know, you can go into
this controller runtime and learn
about all the other things a manager can
provide or a controller can provide
to extend it. And I showed one example
of, say, adding that event recorder because then
when we
like, we didn't have any errors,
but, like, when you
say describe your resource,
if I can type,
you know, we have no events posted. But
say we ran into errors, all of those
would be listed down here.
Okay.
Can we trigger one of those?
Well,
I wonder if I I I don't think
I
I think that would be hard given the
errors that we're checking for right now.
But
because the other thing too is it sets
up a a testing framework,
in the sweet tests.
And so with this simple example,
you know, we're not really checking for, say,
integer
overflows.
And so maybe we pass two integers and
that would then buffer over
overflow
the integer that we're putting it in into,
we could check for that as say a,
as a
test case and then air on that so
that we don't
cause problems.
Okay.
So
what is the sorry. If you is there
something else you wanna go on to before
I just keep throwing stuff at you?
Keep throwing away. Yeah. So, like, you know,
as a a developer. Right? I mean, I'm
sold now is that I I wanna use
the operator SDK if I'm gonna build an
operator. Like, you know, if I were to
make a change to this code now, say
we wanted add a new event recorder
just every time it's updated and say, oh,
we changed the value from the value change
from this test or whatever. Like, what's my
development experience like? How do I just do
go run and it runs on the cluster?
Do I have to build the image? Do
need to use other tools, like, scaffold or
tell? Like, what is the the kind of
process? So,
you know, we could say do a
R recorder.
We're gonna post it to our sync. Because
we could also add events to other
resources within
but we'll add it to our instance here,
event
type info.
Well
You're gonna have to get Kubernetes in there
somewhere too.
Yeah.
And so
if we
let me see if I can build this
quick enough to have it,
add that functionality in. But, basically,
you
would see in the like, if you look
at just a standard event from another resource,
it would just say,
you know,
for for your instance,
we called it five plus seven
info
type sum and then computing sum on Kubernetes.
And, you know, these are useful when you
have business logic that's going to take a
long time.
Yeah.
And so we just add that simple line
and then
Oh, I forgot to do my imports.
But,
I can go back and add that real
quick.
So I'll just share a link on the
screen as well to that repository.
So, you know, feel free to I can
yeah. I can make that public. Right now,
think it's internal to
school people at Uh-huh. Equinix Medal, but,
I will,
I'll I'll talk to my boss. We can
open that up. I don't see that as
a problem.
But, yeah, then you would just make your
image.
So you would make your new image. You,
would then push it to your repository.
And in our config,
manager manager,
you know, this is where it gets deployed.
And so,
if, say, you with your Docker push,
you don't use latest,
you could then update this file here
to
specify
the specific PIN that you wanted to use,
and then
it's just k apply config manager.
I mean, I take it you're just using
Docker for Mac here. Right?
Yes.
Oh, yeah. So, I mean, if
you don't actually need to push that to
a remote repository. Like, if we add image
pool policy,
if not present to that, then it should
just work with the and build Docker for
Mac one. Yeah. I'm actually I'm actually,
using
one of our Kubernetes clusters that are Oh,
nice. Metal. So
not not on my Mac.
That's why some of the, results take a
while to come back.
Right. Okay.
So But, yeah, here,
I do a Docker login to Quay, and
then I push the image
to this packet add operator.
And then I've updated
the config to
use that Quay image.
Okay. And so, yeah, this is this is
running on a fully functional Kubernetes cluster.
Right. Okay.
That that's why we we're not building and
pushing. Got it. That makes sense. So can
we take a, like, take a look at
that struct as well that we defined for
our CRD?
Yeah.
Because I'm thinking, you know, in my head,
what if we've got slightly more complex custom
resources?
Like, is there a way for us
oh, yeah. If I I can see some
sort of annotation stuff here. So maybe we
can go over that. Like, what if I've
got mandatory fields versus optional fields? Is is
there a way for me to kinda specify
that?
I don't think I've gotten into
that
in with my experience yet.
But,
basically, everything is required. So right now.
And so if
I modified
our
add YAML
and I removed add in one,
it's gonna error on us.
Oh.
I cannot type.
Yeah. That's the that's the curse of people
watching you. Your typing spells always go out
the window.
Oh, it's not gonna be required.
But say I added something that wasn't here,
like
That's so weird. I've never seen that yet.
Of course, during demos demonstration.
Yeah. I think Kubernetes is just like I
mean, let's describe it. Let's see what five
plus seven actually looks like in the cluster.
Let's get
or do a dash or YAML, whichever one's
gonna show us more details. Yeah. But I
guess Kubernetes.
So I I actually expected it to work
when you removed one because I've seen an
annotation in your structure that says on the
empty, and that kinda seems to me like
Yeah. Maybe an optional
annotation. I'm not really sure. I'm I'm guessing
more than anything. But
So
it looks like it initialized
add in one to zero even though it's
it wasn't there because it we still have
a sum of seven,
and it didn't air out.
And I think that has to do with
you can specify annotations whether to be strict
or not on your Yeah. Schema.
And so,
I think it would be from what I've
worked with on operators thus far in, like,
the two months I've been working with them,
I
actually air out if we
don't have the information we need. And then
if it's not if it's optional, then you
can default that value or just continue on
without it depending on what the situation is.
That's sweet. Cool.
Alright. If anyone's watching and has any questions,
feel free to drop them in the chat
and we'll tackle them before we we finish
up. I guess I can throw a few
more at you just know where we where
we went.
So let's say let's pop up on a
reconcile function again. Have a look in there.
Oh,
sure.
I think I'm just I'm still kind of
amazed at how little effort is actually required
to to kinda get something
to get something There's a lot of lots
of magic going on.
Yeah. So So, yeah, the only things we
added was where put your logic here,
and we return the result at the end.
So
Yeah. That's pretty cool. I like it.
Yeah. So is there any sorry,
Nico.
Like, another example would be to go
can grab stuff from, say, core b one,
like secret,
and then
specify
the,
you know, name and namespace
of that secret and that you could then
pull that in and manipulate it.
Again, you can, you know, do,
our client get on pretty much any resource
within the communities cluster.
And, you know, typically, that's what you're going
to be doing, grabbing pods, grabbing
secrets,
defining deployments.
Yeah. Definitely.
I I I can
I mean, I guess we're kind of reaching
a stage of
I don't know if it's Kubernetes life cycle
or or whatever, but there's a bit of
a proliferation
of controllers? Like like, everybody seems to have
a controller for almost anything now. And,
you know, when you see something like this
and you're walking through and showing us how
to take
advantage of the operator SDK, you can kind
of understand why. Like, Yeah. Yeah. Because you
you you get a lot from it, like,
know, by defining a couple of structs
angle,
then you get all these custom resources that
are available to your Kubernetes cluster.
We can add the business logic to the
reconcile function and just deploy it. And then
we have our own ability to
tweak the way that Kubernetes works to a
certain degree.
It should Yeah. And I'd also mentioned too
that
operator
Pre one point o is kind of different,
and
I think a little harder to use where
that's why I focused on the one dot
o,
or one dot x series
because,
you know, it already wires up all the
metrics for you, generates even more of the
or, like, hides more of the boilerplate that
you would have to have in your own
files anyways.
And there are a ton of examples, especially
with Golang out there right now. And so
and again, with, you know, hopefully,
improve documentation
and, you know, help the community with that
to to make this even more viable because
it's yeah. Super easy to use and really
nice to get up and running with once
you understand the concepts.
Yeah. Definitely.
Cool. Thank you. Is there anything else you
wanna cover?
I think that's it. People can hit us
up on Twitter after this or
on YouTube and happy to
talk about more operator stuff.
Yeah. Definitely. Feel free to to grab either
of us on Twitter. I think we're we're
both I think it's safe to say that
we both like talking about Kubernetes. So or
Kubernetes. Sorry.
Yeah. Yeah. Definitely.
So like the ad operator, let's talk about
the the why behind. I'm assuming you build
this as a demonstration and a training materials
so that other people can see how to
get started with assess this.
You know, it's it's internal right now. Like,
is it something that you're gonna continue to
add on with more examples?
Like, what what's your plan for the ad
operator?
I think the first thing is to go
back and put some open source slide system
on this and make it a public repository,
and then, you know, work with the community
to provide more examples.
I might just call it, like, the math
operator.
That way we can add,
other,
controllers
in there to show how you would wire
up multiple controllers under one manager,
demonstrate
how you use Ginkgo, which is the testing
framework
Mhmm. And
and check more of those edge cases, like,
say, we're gonna overflow an integer,
you know, how do we wanna handle some
of those edge cases
so that we it's kind
of a secure example.
And then, you know, maybe some more examples
of how you would interact with the Kubernetes
ecosystem,
like, listing,
retrieving objects, updating them
based on it. And that so that might
be just become another operator if we say
move outside of the math concepts.
Yeah. I I I think based on what
you're showing me, I think with my limited
programming skills, even I could probably add like
a subtract controller to this. I I mean,
I think I can maybe handle those five
lines of code. I'm not sure. But at
least I've got you No. I think I
think you should actually
that should be your next task. Exactly. Right?
I should just be like, hey. Let's add
this subtract one. Because I could just add
the types and then the reconciler and then
like, boop boop. And that's just the way
it goes. Yeah. Maybe I will do that
for a bit of fun.
Yeah. It's it's super easy. Send me the
PR.
Alright. Okay. So we just got a couple
of comments there. So great ad pun
and
good values. Because the emoji showed up, it
doesn't
Yeah.
Alright. That was really useful. Really nice introduction
to OperatorSDK.
I'm looking I'm hoping we can open source
this as a bit of a fun experiment
and encourage people to, you know, come along
and and add new types and just I
think it's a really it could be a
really cool and fun educational resource for anyone
that wants to put down this path. Yeah.
It's a great playground.
Yeah. For sure.
Alright. Well, thank you very much, Dennis, for
taking time out of your day to join
me today and to putting that together and
walking us through it. Really useful. So My
pleasure. Thanks for having me again. And then
we'll try and maybe organize a part two
then once we get us open source and
see what we can do. Absolutely.
Sounds good. Sweet. Thank you. Have a great
day and Thanks.
Bye.